McDonald's people are not happy with
them and their score on the American
customer service index is falling let's
take a look so this is a favorability
score for pretty big chain restaurants
fast food restaurants we do a bunch of
fast food stuff here and people people
are always very passionate about it so
Papa John's doing pretty well they got
82 out of 100 which is they didn't move
from last year people like them in 2013
they like them in 2014
Pizza Hut number two so people seem to
really like generic chain pizza does
that where do you guys fall on that from
the Midwest I didn't know there was
anything more exotic than a Pizza Hut
but away from there I don't know how you
could stop right so this is like New
York obviously you're not gonna go to
Pizza Hut or Domino's or Papa John's got
real Pete's all right let's go back to
the chart there and again then then
Little Caesars and Domino's Pizza so the
first four people are very satisfied
with shitty pizza but then okay so then
on the bottom the last four Burger King
Dunkin Donuts KFC Taco Bell in Mikado's
like I gave you five there so McDonald's
really kind of struggling and I was when
I was watching this I'm thinking you
know people have said that their numbers
there their take-home right now is
dropping a little bit but is this partly
just people like to beat up on the thing
that they secretly love like everyone
talks [ __ ] about Walmart and everyone
shops there you know although I actually
I went there to get a big-screen TV and
the customer service was so bad I
actually brought the TV up carry the TV
myself brought it to the register and he
was taking so long and they were being
so unpleasant I just left it there like
Jerry Seinfeld you returned the sports
coat Oh spike but really you think
that's some of what's going on here like
McDonald's hasn't changed that much so
there's no reason you know oh yeah all
the lies it was all the lies in the
world I tell people I hate McDonald's
because I was just supposed to say woman
oh and then you go and you buy the
entire dollar menu and you sit in your
room eagerly yes madam
you can't say that you like it because
it's just in this day and age what
everyone wants to be organic and natural
and gluten-free and XY and Z you can't
say you like me how do you feel after
you've done that in your room just pour
it all that we should all go out for
McDonald's maybe you could what do you
is this like secret hate like yeah
absolutely disagree for one reason yeah
because I don't know if it was 2 days
ago or yesterday the the abominable
horrible thing that happened to that
little girl at KFC when she was mauled
by a dog and she was scarred and the
family took her into KFC and they asked
her to leave a little girl because she
was making the other customers
uncomfortable if that's what customer
service is at fast-food [ __ ] all of them
yeah and that is what a lot of customer
services they're not all of course
deserve to fall by the way I'm pretty
sure KFC has now helped her pay some
medical bills or something so I
understand the corporate wasn't there
and this is just some dude trying it
whatever I can't cover up to $30,000 for
medical bills or millions in the lawsuit
you know blame the founder of blame the
colonel for this happening but I do
understand you know they probably
wouldn't have wanted their employee to
treat another person like that but if
that's the culture you're breeding then
I don't feel sorry for you right and
there is a lot of that because here even
in LA now that I want to make everything
about LA but if you were to go to an in
and out in it they smile they're
friendly I mean they make a point of
service to the eye they are happy to be
there
McDonald's they don't give a flying [ __ ]
about you and I get it they're paying
different things and there's different
business model that but I'm glad you
brought up KFC because the other two so
at the bottom we're KFC and Taco Bell
Taco Bell I think has the reverse thing
I mean isn't it cool to like Taco Bell
if you it is for further
there you know they got the Doritos the
kids love it there's some Taco Bell
plays yeah that commercial but the old
people in everything kids love it so I
think they get the reverse thing somehow
it's cool to say that you like Taco Bell
not cool to say you like me that Sam I
think completely is the same thing as
the movie idiocracy they marry each
other
you can take nine ingredients and
shuffle the deck in a different way and
get a whole new product and get people
excited they're geniuses
we're morons but they're geniuses by the
way in the movie idiocracy which is such
an underrated movie that's really so
spectacular the one fast-food restaurant
that survives the future is Carl's jr.
which didn't which is horrible which is
horrible now and didn't even make can we
talk about why filets not on the list
they have the best customers though
they're always like you know what we had
a kerosene Maria and a couple weeks ago
and she made the same argument I love
that I love gay people like what you
know you can't win you can't win
oh he's in life anyway the point is
McDonald's it's just not that great and
you'd probably be happier elsewhere